bonjour à tous les deux
merci beaucoup d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors on va
parler de jean michel blanquer requis a
défendu qui a dénoncé la semaine
dernière l'entrée du pronom yale dans le
petit robert le ministre de l'éducation
nationale vent debout contre la culture
work suite à l'entrée du pronom yale
dans le petit robert françois jolivet
est député la république en marge de
l'indre s'en est indigné il a qualifié
ces auteurs de militants d'une cause qui
n'a rien de français le hoki sme ecoutez
jean michel bancaire qui le soutient je
soutiens évidemment la protestation de
françois jolivet vis-à-vis du petit
robert l'écriture inclusive n'est pas
l'avenir de la langue française alors
même que nos élèves sont justement en
train de consolider leurs savoirs
fondamentaux il ne saurait avoir cela
pour référence votre réaction maxence
briquet c'est intéressant parce que on a
une jeunesse ce matin sur ce plateau
donc on la culture ok qui concerne
particulièrement les jeunes on va le
voir votre réaction à ce qu'a dit jean
michel blanquer sur l'introduction du
pronom yale dans le petit robert
vous entend pas très bien maxence
briquet
on va poser la question à léon des
fontaines
alors sur sur le débat autour du
dictionnaire parce que c'est un débat
autour du dictionnaire avant tout moi je
vous avoue avoir été assez assez choqué
du de la teneur des propos de la
république en marche en fait celle c'est
juste d'ajouter un mot dans le
dictionnaire est de faire référencer les
usages
oui absolument mais ça a suscité
beaucoup de débats au sein de la classe
politique
ça ne fait pas partie de la culture
française a dit notamment le françois
jolivet le député la république en marge
de l'indre vous n'êtes donc pas d'accord
avec ça les ondes et fontaine non moi je
pense que la langue française c'est une
langue vivante qui évolue avec le temps
maintenant ce qu'il ajoute ce
dictionnaire n'aurait faire ensemble
aucun cas un remplacement des pronoms il
elle c'est un ajout dans le dictionnaire
vous par exemple si vous posiez la
question il ya un mois peut-être de moi
sur ce que ça voulait dire yale beaucoup
ne savaient pas d'ailleurs pour
l'anecdote j'ai questionné hier un ami
parce que je lui ai dit que je passais
soi r t il m'a dit qu'est ce que ça veut
dire il ya les jeudis bat on ouvre le
petit robert sait que dedans tu pourras
te de voir la définition de ce que c'est
que ce mot là et donc je pense que c'est
important d'avoir un dictionnaire pour
ces choses-là et un dictionnaire ça sert
avant tout à cela en aucun cas
aujourd'hui les programmes français
d'enseigner dans l'épreuve de français
oui c'est vrai que c'est les
dictionnaires évolué il ya des nouveaux
mots chaque année est-ce qu'on vous
entende accents sourit qu'à une réaction
à l'introduction de yale dans le petit
robert
non on a un problème technique
malheureusement avec maxence briquet
j'espère que ça va être résolu et ont
des fontaines donc on va continuer à se
débarrasser ce que c'est une souvent s
on dit que c'est une minorité qui impose
sa vision la société a une majorité est
ce que c'est un phénomène d' importance
réelle selon vous le phénomène au wac
non je pense pas je pense que
malheureusement d'ailleurs à chaque fois
qu'on traite au conte parlent d'anti
racisme et des luttes antiracistes on
prend par le petit bout de la lorgnette
et on observe le moment aucun
aujourd'hui le mouvement atteint
antiracistes et large dans la cité
française il est d'ailleurs très
largement majoritaire et ça voudrait
peut-être le coup des fois de de se
focaliser un peu sur ce que disent la
majorité justement de la militants
antiracistes et en aucun cas il se
revendique du oak hills d'ailleurs en
parlant du caucus du qu'on ait un débat
sur le dictionnaire je vous avoue
malavoy avoir du mal à comprendre ce
qu'on met derrière cette idéologie ou au
coq isme la question si c'est ce que de
lutter contre les discriminations
et la société des genres et la société
je sais pas moi je j'ai eu plein de
définition différente à chaque passage
médiatique on a une nouvelle une
nouvelle définition est-ce qu'il faut
lutter contre les stéréotypes de genre
je le pense profondément
aujourd'hui on encore des inégalités
très fort dans la société française
notamment les inégalités salariales par
exemple de six engagés pour lutter
contre l'inégalité entre les hommes et
les femmes moi si je me retrouve
pleinement la dent je ne pense pas que
le mot qui ce monsieur soit ça après on
en parlait mais c'est vrai que signé de
logique et assez flou on va en parler
alors
qu on vous entend à présent maxence
briquet on vous à part par téléphone je
répète donc ma question votre réaction
tout d'abord un introduction du pronom
yale dans le petit larousse et et du
veau qui sont en général
le gauchisme en fait en train de
s'insinuer dans la langue française mais
il n'est pas que question d'aaland en
fait il est vraiment question de mener
une bataille culturelle une idéologie
c'est un peu ce que disait lénine c'est
à dire vous leur fait avaler le mot vous
leur ferez avaler la chose c'est
exactement ce qu'a essayé de faire les
militants rock aujourd'hui de faire
entrer l'écriture inclusive vers la
langue française pour faire croire qu
est ce qu on veut les promoteurs du miel
désir en quelque sorte subvertir la
logique notre langue à déstabilisant sur
un point assez décisif qui est la
dualité des steaks et je pense que j'en
retiens le banc car à raison de s'ériger
contre 7,7 folie linguistique alors que
gabri à la tall a voulu rassurer en
disant qu' évidemment là est la position
du gouvernement est claire écoutez le
la position du gouvernement
elle éclaire pas d'écriture inclusive
dans les documents officiels et
l'éducation nationale ça c'est la ligne
officielle et ont des fontaines est ce
que vous êtes d'accord ce qu'il faut
utiliser cette écriture inclusive c'est
le cas notamment dans l'administration
parisienne
mois sur cette utilisation de yale moi
je pense qu'il faut voir l' usage c'est
les françaises et les français qui
décideront de savoir s'ils utilisent si
on le français est une langue vivante
c'est bien parce que justement les
français se sont appropriés des fois des
nouveaux mots on nous devons arrêter
d'en utiliser d'autres et la langue
évolue comme ça et c'est ça la richesse
d'une culture à l'heure actuelle une
année enfin le lusage du yale et ultra
minorité instruments pour faire changer
la société française non pour moi c'est
un usage de certaines personnes un petit
groupe de personnes et c'est vrai que
moi même il y a quelques mois je me suis
questionnée sur ce que c'était que ce
qu'elle est j'étais bien heureux de
trouver la définition et je pense que
justement le fait de l'inclure dans le
dictionnaire permet d'apporter la
définition à tout le monde si jamais un
moment ou un autre on est confronté à se
prononcer qu'il ya quelques usages quand
même dans la langue française sur qui à
quelques français qui utilisent cette ce
pronom et ben je pense que c'est bien de
pouvoir accéder à cette définition ça
s'arrête là je pense que jean michel
blanquer râlons s'est volontairement par
contre une polémique là-dessus
alors qu'aujourd'hui la scène de
l'éducation nationale est dans un état
déplorable venir polémiquer sur
l'inclusion d'un pro d'un nouveau
prônons d'un nouveau mode ailleurs
actionnaire heureusement qu'on ne
commande pas en cas de chaque mot dans
chaque dictionnaire je pense qu'un futur
président de la république a autre chose
à faire le commenter les ajouts dans les
dictionnaires alors après il invoque
aussi la difficulté déjà à l'école
puisque on va le voir 7% de la
population adulte scolarisés en france
est en situation d'illettrisme moins
d'un élève sur deux ans en début de
sixième est capable d'accorder
correctement le verbe à son sujet dans
la phrase rajouter des mots ça complique
les choses maxence briquet qu'en pensez
vous et et d'ailleurs qu'est qui utilise
le mot yale aujourd'hui est ce que ce
sont les jeunes
ou est-ce que c'est révélateur d'une
société plus large toutes cases
confondues
c'est à dire que vous disiez monsieur
que l'oeil elle était là parce qu'il
était utilisé que du coup c'était
important que qu'ils soient référencés
le dictionnaire mais en fait personne
utilise ce mot c'est justement le
problème c'est à dire que vous avez un
des rédacteurs de robert qui s'est dit
qu'ils allaient pouvoir mener bataille
culturelle dans son point qu'il allait
envoyer le pronom yale comme ça sur le
devant de la scène et ça fait polémique
justement parce que les français sont
unanimement contre il trouve que c'est
vraiment un dévoiement de ski françaises
et vous parliez de ce que de ce que
vivent les élèves aujourd'hui à l'école
de leurs difficultés et très franchement
je vois mal comment est ce qu'on
pourrait penser que le fait de mettre
des points partout des points 1 point s
pour essayer de faire du spécifique dans
la nature des gens pour aider les
étudiants écoliers a
aussi devenir français rappelle quand
même que la langue française c'est le
vecteur de la culture les ondes et fonda
et voulait réagir en fait il a jamais il
n'a jamais été question de l'inclure
dans les programmes de français encore
une fois on voit las de ce que vous
faites que non seulement vous vous
reposez sur le mensonge mais aujourd'hui
il n'y a aucun débat de savoir si on
allait remplacer ils et elles parriel ça
jamais été question ça n'a fait un grand
pas dans les programmes c'est quelque
chose qu'on a ajouté mais visiblement
les militants de l'extrême droite en
effet un peu de mal à voir que quand on
ajoute on retire pas donc je pense que
il ya aussi un problème en france c'est
certes mais également un problème
visiblement mathématiques et ça serait
bien de revoir ses poches alors on va
quand même une chose aussi qui est sorti
hier c'est un lexique du parler
politiquement correct par la commission
européenne
un lexique qui bannit par exemple des
listes de mots et des expressions au nom
de la lutte pour l'égalité des gens une
police du vocabulaire en quelque sorte
qu'en pensez vous je sais pas si vous en
avez eu connaissance maxence briquet on
ne peut plus dire par exemple mesdames
messieurs on va dire chers collègues
qu'en pensez vous
bah gens pensent que c'est absolument
déplorable métaphore bien en fait dans
les idéologies walk aujourd'hui c'est à
dire que si vous prenez par exemple le
catalogue disney matin il y en a
certains des dessins animés pour enfants
qui ont été retirées parce que il
pourrait mettre en avant telle ou telle
forme de discrimination vraiment c c
dans l'air du temps de voir des
discriminations partout et de raisonner
dans tous les sens du terme avec le lait
rapport dominant-dominé et de la langue
française avec capture inclusif très
justement que ce que l'ue augmente de
mettre en place mais aujourd'hui sans
doute pas la commission open est devenu
hop
absolument oui il supporte qui s'est
passé avec ce n'est pas la commission
est une instance européenne qui a fait
la promotion du jab avec une poigne
publicitaire qui était absolument
incroyable il faut bien comprendre quand
même que l'europe c'est pas juste une
bureaucratie d'administration c'est
aussi une civilisation et aujourd'hui
c'est la commission européenne c'est
juste une espèce de deux succursales de
ce que les états unis font et on a su
marquer l'avant avec les états unis n'a
pas vocation à créer des discriminations
raciales on n'a pas vocation à faire des
différents comme ça entre les catégories
de population sur des bases complètement
fou buzz donc oui on se pose
complètement contre ça est ce que le
genre est devenu tabou
léon des fontaines suite à ce manifeste
de la commission européenne et même les
images elles encouragent par exemple à
ne plus prendre en photo
un groupe de deux messieurs si je peux
utiliser ce terme de messieurs en
cravate sans la présence d'une femme sur
la photo heureusement il ya les merkel
ces seize dernières années mais ça
complique les choses quand même non
jeu bon déjà je pense pas que la
commission européenne soit au cou
islamistes ou je ne sais pas quoi comme
des sessions d'entraînement des batteurs
mais sur
sur le politiquement correct ne plus
pouvoir utiliser mesdames messieurs ont
aujourd'hui encore une fois c'est l'
usage qui prime et l'usagé aujourd'hui
la plupart du temps
les députés par exemple sont fortement
encouragés à suivre ce petit manifeste
pas pour l'instant moi j'en ai pas
entendu beaucoup qu'il utilise donc on
verra bien rien de temps ce sera 20 ni
pauvre ni la première ni la dernière
résolution de la commission open qui
pourtant sont potentiellement ne portera
pas ses fruits mais sur sur le
le voilà ils se comptent encore pas du
genre moi je pense que l'important c'est
important aujourd'hui de pouvoir parler
du genre de pouvoir parler notamment des
inégalités j'en ai peut-être qu'un des
défauts de cette commission open
c'est bien ça le problème non justement
aujourd'hui il ya des inégalités il ya
des différentes certes biologique pas
entre les gens nés entre le sexe mais il
ya aussi une différence genre et dans la
société qui est profondément
inégalitaire nil et l'inégalité entre
les salaires des hommes et des femmes
c'est aujourd'hui ne pas admettre la
vérité à mettre une réelle
mais l'un des problèmes l'un des
problèmes de la commission européenne
probablement quand même parce que je
critique à huningue à tous cette
résolution c'est que elle vise plutôt à
masquer le problème que s'attaquer à la
racine du mal
et aujourd'hui c'est peut-être ça qu'on
peut déplorer de la part de l'union
européenne c'est que souvent il essaye
de masquer les problèmes de nier les
problèmes avec le
pape face à l'idéologie walk jean michel
blanquer encore lui annonçait un plan
européen pour le latin et le grec
regarder
ce qui fédère d'abord les pays européens
ce sont les langues antiques et bien
évidemment avec ce fond linguistique
commun rayonne des valeurs communes
l'humanisme le culte du vrai et du beau
l'exigence du logo ce qui se révèle si
nécessaire à notre époque où la déraison
fait feu de tout bois
un commentaire maxence briquet je suis
sûr que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
absolument oui je trouve que c'est un
très beau projet de civilisation que de
vouloir revenir au fondement de ce qui
fait la beauté de la langue française
qui aujourd'hui nous permet aussi de
rayonner à l'international à la
francophonie c'est quelque chose
d'absolument incroyable sa porte des
valeurs les valeurs de la france sa
porte une culture sa porte une histoire
c'est qu'elle parle on parle de la
promotion des langues antiques
qui ont été aux commandes alors
française en étant d'accord là dessus
c'est sur ça que ce soit la civilisation
occidentale sur les ondes et fontaine ça
vous paraît un peu rétrograde de base
est de promouvoir le grec et le latin
aujourd'hui
de base et le programme de swiss à ce
qu'avait trop grade maintenant qu'ils
sont renseignés mois appartement il a
les enseignements je pense ça se
réfléchit ça se construit je suis pas
opposé à sa part contre jean-michel
dockers qui dit qu'il va promouvoir le
latin le grec je pense qu'il va le
promouvoir encore une fois sur forme
d'options qui va être réservé à aux
enfants des classes privilégiées qui va
créer l'égalité et je veux bien aussi
que francesca viennent on peut rajouter
au programme et lorsqu'on retire des
enseignants lorsqu'on paul tear des
heures j'ai lu un article dans les échos
hier qui sait qu'on avait retiré des
heures de maths par exemple notamment
lycée à un moment on va voir où on
priorise sur le terrain et on a retiré
beaucoup d'heures de français également
et on a retiré beaucoup d'heures de
français également ça c'est une erreur
ah oui c'est une grave erreur c'est une
grave erreur que ça soit les heures de
français les ordres de manuel
mathématiques les matières fondamentales
aujourd'hui la réalité c'est en haute
tarentaise or en réalité
l'éducation et l'état recule parce que
derrière ça veut dire ceux qui ont les
moyens pour faire appel à des instituts
privés par compléter leurs cours et les
autres ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens ou
ont simplement peur de pau je suis sûr
que mon débatteurs sera d'accord que
pour dire si on veut justement une
nation forte qui soit capable de
de faire vivre la queue et vivre et
d'être formés va falloir mettre des
ordres et aujourd'hui vers le haut tout
compte maxence briques le mcs son
briquet réaction
ben évidemment enfin c'est à dire que le
déclassement français vient aussi en
grande part du fait que l'école a
complètement complètement perdu pied
c'est à dire que les vieilles idéologies
que ce soit en histoire là m la
médiocrité qu'on a en mathématiques même
en france est notre langue qui est même
très mal parlé par les étudiants et les
élèves qui arrivent au collège c'est
absolument dramatique sauf qu'en fait je
viens avec les syracuse is sure
m'installe sa une comme une passion d'un
store ça dans les programmes cela plus
limité des cours de français caf a
racheté ce sera des cours de magie en
fait parce que ces gens-là crois qu'en
manipulant les signes qui peuvent être
inscrits sur un support on peut changer
le monde en fait c'est pire que
d'idéologie c'est le retour de
l'incantation c'est de la pensée magique
presque il ya une levée de boucliers
cette semaine contre rama yade
l'ancienne secrétaire d'état de nicolas
sarkozy a dénoncé dans une interview à
l'express le 19 novembre dernier le
privilège blanc et a défini le walkie
sme comme un noble combat regarder
passer à paris devant la figure de
colbert ce grand ennemi de la liberté
dont la statue et devant l'assemblée
nationale est une micro agression à léon
des fontaines comment avez vous réagi à
ces propos
déjà j'étais choqué de l'évolution
critique de rama yade maintenant sur le
jeu des anneaux mais c'est sûr que sur
l'enjeu de déboulonner les statues ou
quoi je pense que l'histoire française
est une histoire complexe qui ne doit
pas être simplifié qui doit être
enseignée et détaillée et notamment à
travers les personnages historiques
typiquement colbert moi je pense que
c'est quelqu'un qui ne faut pas le faire
disparaître du programme de l'histoire
au contraire il faut pouvoir montrer
toute l'ambiguïté de ce personnage et
notamment ce qu'il a fait de mal et
peut-être en signer davantage par
exemple le code noir où il en est à
l'origine qui a comparé quand même une
partie de l'humanité à des meubles et je
pense que c'est important l'enseigné je
pense que c'est aussi important
d'enseigner l'histoire dans toute sa
complexité de mettre en avant toutes les
personnalités qui ont fait l'histoire
internationale et moi je pense à
certaines figures du des colonialismes
qui sont pas mis en avant par exemple
toussaint louverture qui a lutté pour
l'indépendance ait itunes personnage un
personnage historique très intéressant à
étudier ce que je déplore aujourd'hui et
je me joins à l'intervention précédente
c'est que des fois l'histoire est
peut-être un peu trop simplifié or
l'euro en france l histoire en fait
l'histoire internationale et une
histoire beaucoup trop complexe pour
être simplifiées comme ça et en effet on
est amis trêve l'enseigné de footeux
toute l'histoire dans sa construction
d'ambiguïté dans tout cela est
aujourd'hui malheureusement on est
plutôt à retirer des heures
maxence brique est votre réaction à
l'ancienne secrétaire d'état qui dit
qu'elle ait dit ce qu'il ya vraiment une
discrimination blanche alors qu'elle a
été secrétaire d'état
j'ai trouvé vraiment pas lorsque j'ai
été choqué de la même manière en lisant
les temps sur l'interview je trouve
vraiment que cette réaction est à vomir
c'est à dire que on a eu une personne
qui a qui a réussi qui est devenu
ministre grâce à la méritocratie
républicaine et qui aujourd'hui en fait
en train de cracher sur absolument tous
tout ce qui se fait sa réussite le
travail la méritocratie vos branches
course absolument scandaleux de d'en
arriver à ce point en plus à s'auto
essentialiser parce qu'en fait elle
seule elle se ramène elle même à sa
couleur de peau alors que c'est l'exact
inverse de ce que fait l'universalisme à
la française sur l'enseignement de
l'histoire par contre je m'inscris
totalement en faux avec ce que vient de
faire un interlocuteur c'est à dire que
vous vous dites qu'il faut enseigner
l'histoire dans toute la complexité de
l'avion est complètement d'accord et
derrière vous dites que le code noir a
été une abomination complète et que
c'est terrible alors le fait de
considérer qu'une noire son esclave est
une abomination en revanche a
considérablement amélioré leur sort donc
je vous invite à ouvrir un bouquin
d'histoire et a essayé de la présidente
complexité contrairement à ce que vous
faire et ont défoncé une réaction
d'améliorer la condition des esclaves
c'est marcher sur la tête c'est fou la
preuve en est d'ailleurs que lui voulait
peut-être les cours d'histoire ne sont
pas assez bien enseigner vous qui
défendez l'éducation nationale depuis
tout à l'heure on a vu les mathématiques
l'histoire c'est pas votre fort attendez
on peut pas dire que le code noir à être
permis de d'améliorer la condition de
vie des esclaves
au collège du coup pour avoir une
actrice complète de l'histoire alors ce
sera l'objet là ce sera l'objet d'un
futur débat je vous le promets merci
beaucoup en tout cas merci maxence
briques et merci à vous les ondées
front-end avoir débattu ce matin sur la
langue française sur notre plateau m 6